bit of breaking news to bring you and
we've just heard from buckingham palace
that the queen will receive prime
minister boris johnson on tuesday
september the 6th at balmoral so that's
breaking with tradition because it's
usually at buckingham palace and that
meeting will be followed by an audience
with the new prime minister following
that tory leadership contest
as we said that's come from buckingham
palace in the last few moments we can go
live to our royal correspondent rhiannon
mills now for some more detail rhiannon
presumably at balmoral because of the
queen's mobility issues
so at the moment the bahalis aren't
giving us any more details exactly why
they've decided to make this change but
this is a huge
break with tradition throughout her
reign she has always appointed her prime
ministers
at buckingham palace so this is a big
announcement coming from the palace
today and i think of course we have to
look back at the fact that certainly
over the last
10 to 12 months we've increasingly been
talking about the queen's mobility
issues about the fact that the palace
have had to be a bit more practical when
it comes to what exactly they're asking
the 96 year old monarch to do has to be
said it isn't a huge surprise that
they've now announced that this is
actually going to take place up in
scotland she of course is carrying out
her holiday up there she traveled up to
scotland at the end of july she always
spends
august and september up in balmoral she
loves that chance to have family time
up there also has to be said there's
nothing unconstitutional about the fact
that she will accept boris johnson's
resignation and then appoint a new prime
minister up in balmoral she of course is
able to to carry out engagements up
there but this is going to be an
enormous change from what we've seen
throughout her 70 year reign and i have
been there on numerous occasions outside
of buckingham palace and it's all become
part of the theatre really the fact that
we've always seen those cars with an
outgoing prime minister traveling from
downing street all the way down the mail
to buckingham palace the prime minister
walking in offering his resignation
having his final audience with the queen
there at buckingham palace and then very
quickly it all changes we have that
handover and the new prime minister then
gets to go and have their first audience
uh with her majesty instead it's going
to look very different next week on
tuesday instead we're not exactly sure
how but we're going to have the outgoing
prime minister so boris johnson and his
successor both whizzing up to scotland
to have what ultimately is a very short
engagement with the queen often only
taking place over about 30 minutes 40
minutes probably um over a cup of tea i
think for the palace it's really
important to think that they know well
they've been probably mulling over the
optics of all of this you've got a
couple of things going on number one of
course we talk a great deal at the
moment don't we about politicians
members they're all family using uh
aircraft using helicopters using planes
is it unnecessary during this time when
we're talking about the climate crisis
so does it necessarily look that great
that boris johnson and his successor are
going to be having to head all the way
up to scotland but also i think
significantly again it does mean that
many people will be talking about the
queen's health
and her mobility issues there is no
doubt that the queen herself will have
wanted to carry out what is a really
important part of her constitutional
duties yes throughout her reign there's
increasingly been this distance between
her actually deciding who the next prime
minister is going to be but it's always
been very important that she has been
the one who has appointed the next prime
minister in essence handing over that
executive power so we are still going to
see that take place uh up in scotland
next week also it's going to be
fascinating to see whether or not we're
actually going to see the queen before
that we haven't actually seen her since
she arrived in scotland we know that the
usual ceremony where she arrives at
balmoral that had to be cancelled and
was carried out in private for her
comfort however this weekend you have
got the bremar gathering coming up so
that's the highland games which we know
that she absolutely loves so we wait to
see whether or not we see her at that on
saturday but of course the big moment is
going to be tuesday where she is going
to welcome boris johnson for one final
time and of course we wait and see
whether or not it's going to be liz
truss or rishi sunak who are also
heading to scotland to see the queen